welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in previous episodes
i've mentioned my experience
hallucinating a purple goddess woman
on a seriously high dose of shrooms in a
very intense part of my life
and then seeing her again on aco dmt
it turns out that this hallucination is
actually rather common and i was told
that the guests i speak with in this
episode
shane moss had an extensive relationship
with the purple woman
same one who knows i thought delving
into that would make an insanely
interesting episode
so here it is we covered a lot i went
into excruciating detail about the
shrooms trip i had
which i haven't covered elsewhere shane
moss is a stand-up comedian
psychonaut and science enthusiast who
has his own podcast called here we are
podcast he's also the creator of the
documentary psychonauts
a comics exploration of psychedelics
this episode isn't all positive
we went into the potential dangers of
psychedelics too let me know what you
think also
here's a poster i was sent by hawk on
hism
drawing his interpretation of
the purple woman sorry people listening
to audio you can't see this
but it's the face of a purple goddess
lady almost
identical to what i saw
except the lady i saw was definitely a
black woman
for whatever reason anyway check out his
art it's incredible
a hawk on hism on instagram
h-a-k-a-n-h-i-s-i-m
this episode is brought to you by a
kratom sponsor
the company is called superspeciosa a
bit about kratom
kratom is a herb related to the coffee
plant if you tried cbd and you felt like
it isn't quite what you're looking for
or even if you like cbd but you want to
try something else
kratom might be for you there have also
been reports of kratom abuse
but whenever you try anything don't be
stupid don't drink 12 cups of coffee a
day or you'll get withdrawal
don't overdo it on anything except steak
do your research and decide
i myself like kratom and think it can be
beneficial if used properly
i've used it as a substitute for coffee
coffee doesn't make me feel very good
or as an overall calming tea some people
use it to manage stress and to help them
relax
i know how hard this year has been and
is on people
and something like kratom tea is way
safer in my opinion than a
pharmaceutical quality matters
i had a terrible experience in the
summer with kratom i got from a super
sketchy corner store in florida
super speciosa is great it's reliable
third party lab tested and approved
under the american kratom association's
quality standards program
only natural kratom no other ingredients
superspeciosa has provided the option to
cut out the middleman
instead of buying kratom at a random
shop like i did which actually ended up
making me really ill
visit getsuperleaf.com mp
to buy small servings or in bulk either
way you'll save
lots of money to get guaranteed high
quality kratom
so if you want to try kratom you can get
20 off by going to getsuperleaf.
mp enter the code mp for 20
off that's get super leaf dot com slash
mp
promo code mp for 20 off thanks super
speciosa
for the sponsorship and if you're more
interested in short form content
because you have an attention span like
a goldfish like me check out my clips
channel
linked in the pinned comment on youtube
or at mckayla peterson clips on youtube
we have short clips from podcasts in
there if you enjoyed this episode please
leave me a review i love reading them
for the most part
there are always some enjoy this episode
[Music]
shane moss welcome to my podcast thank
you
thank you for having me okay i've been
looking forward to this for
a little bit i don't think i reached out
to you very long ago
but what happened on my end is i was
talking about
i had this insane a couple of insane
um like psychedelic experiences last
year
and so i've mentioned this purple god
woman that i've seen and i've mentioned
it a couple of times in podcasts
and a couple weeks ago i mentioned it on
instagram and somebody was like
you should reach out to shane moss
because he has a ton of stories
about this purple lady and so i went to
your profile and then i found
this picture on there um
where somebody had drawn
this [ __ ] yes hawkinism yeah
in turkey and he'd drawn this woman and
i was like that looks
almost identical to what i've seen
uh and so then i reached out because i
was like this is
weird uh yeah this is weird
so i guess can we start off by you just
giving a brief
background to my audience uh to who just
to start with who you are
sure sure uh yeah well okay so i've
er the relevant things i've been a
comedian for
16 years and i
halfway through my so early on in my
career i was fortunate and caught a
bunch of breaks and got to do like late
night things and
comedy central things and all these uh
things that gave me uh enough impressive
sounding credits to be able to be a
full-time comedian
um making my living on the road uh which
i've been doing full-time for 14 years
and
about midway through my career uh
but right around the age of 30 or so
i i wanted to kind of be talking about
more meaningful things i was kind of a
short joke absurdist
one-liner-ish kind of guy and and i
wanted to have more substance in the
things that i was
talking about i was always really big
into just having
big intellectual conversations with
people and didn't know
really how to do that in the world of
comedy but podcasting was
was new then and it was opening a lot of
doors for comedians like myself to
kind of share their perspectives more
and i
long story short i i my
science enthusiasm ended up
turning into a science podcast called
here we are where i
interview a different scientist each
week so i didn't i didn't go to college
i'm
from a small town in wisconsin i did a
lot of factory work and
blue collar upbringing and all of that
kind of stuff and
so i i just in my in my travels i wanted
to just
look up different people and be like hey
this person researches
ants at this university or whatever just
weird and and learn more and educate
myself that way
and it just became more and more a
bigger part of what i was doing and i
started doing themed shows that had like
a scientific bent to them
i did a special on netflix called mating
season which is no longer on there which
i'm kind of grateful for because i kind
of hated it
it's the only thing that i ever recorded
that i wasn't happy with
and but it was my first little trial
into that and then i started doing other
themed things i did
i made an album called my big break much
about the negativity bias and how we
evolved
uh to kind of focus on negative emotions
and whatnot
and then uh in promoting that
i was on this guy pete holmes podcast uh
you made it weird he asked me how i
broke my feet which was the basis of
this
album that i put out and i was like well
i was going to sedona arizona
uh what were you doing there well i was
going to do ayahuasca for the first time
what's ayahuasca where this
well there's a stuffed dmt that i smoke
what's dmt and i started talking about
dmt
and turns out once you start talking
about dmt
people really want to hear a lot more
about it
and then out of nowhere i kind of i
guess i became this like
psychedelic guy i i had all of this
material about psychedelics
and started doing indie shows about them
and um and sometimes i get pigeonholed
as
as a psychedelic comic more than i'd
like but anyway
it got me it got me into um doing indie
shows and
and uh and kind of becoming a
psychedelic advocate and stuff
psychedelics i've been doing for about
years dmt i i did for the first time
like
eight or nine years ago and uh and
so yeah and then this purple woman that
i've had a
weird exchange with it seems like a lot
of people all over the world has
uh have had a a somewhat similar
experience
so that's uh hopefully not overly
long-winded but it'll give up plenty of
context for the conversation
no that was perfect so i've
i'm shocked that i well i'm shocked and
not shocked that other people
have had similar experiences i've heard
of people going to do
ayahuasca and forests and having group
hallucinations
when you know how is that possible how
can separate people
take a drug and see the same thing if
it's purely
in your head and i posted yesterday i
posted on instagram
you know do you have questions about
this and obviously a ton of people did
but a lot of it was
a lot of it was one are you sure this
isn't something demonic
and and two aren't you aware that this
is just a hallucination
which are definitely comments done by
people who haven't hallucinated before
yeah yeah so can we start i guess
with why do you think so
let no let's start the very basic like
what was your experience what's been
your experience with this purple woman
sure would you would you mind just for a
little context
if if you haven't if you don't think
you've shared it too much
could you tell me a little bit about
your experience oh i'm gonna go first
okay
is that i haven't i haven't i haven't
really gotten into it on a podcast yet
and i wrote down the entire
thing right after first if you want what
do you prefer
um no no let's do it let's do it i'll
get into it um i'll give you the it's
not going to be the like
you know 10 page thing i wrote down but
last
so last year i think it was november
uh i was i was kind of at a point in my
life where i was making
serious decisions i had separated i was
separated from my husband
uh for about a year and a half and
i kind of like sorted out my head in
that year and a half and i got to a
place where i felt stable enough to be
able to do a high dose of a psychedelic
at that point it's psilocybin so uh
i i felt stable enough i was like you
know what i'm gonna be able to go into
this and learn something
so i had seven grams in tea
and that's a good amount oh my god
i'm actually a fan of larger doses i'm
not
i i don't like to be prescriptive to
anybody else but for myself personally
i i think yeah the five grams was what
terence mckenna
would call the heroic deals which i
thought was the most poorly named
i i i wish he wouldn't have
made it sound like such a heroic journey
or whatever but i actually think that's
a good place to start
so anyways really i i do
oh wow i'd had like i've i've done them
a bunch before that i'd never done that
many
i'd done two i i didn't really like
anything under two
i found two to three and a half got me
to this point where i had a lot of
control over it and it was kind of this
uncomfortable
period where i was like oh maybe i don't
want to venture into that and i could
try really hard and stop myself but i
find for me
anything over four uh and i don't have
an option
yeah i i don't like giving myself the
option i i find
that uh anxiety those middle grounds are
unsettling and more confusing and they
can be helpful as well but they've
they've they've actually the the half
the half dose
so in in many psilocybin and mdma trials
they've done full dose placebo and then
for a while they were doing half doses
and they
they've cut half doses from really
studies that i know for that very reason
they've actually they've actually seen
people
have a uh if anything sometimes negative
impact from
from the half doses or or interesting
not not as much help so so usually
there's
there's some help within the placebo
group because you're still getting
lots of therapy and everything and then
there's uh
a huge impact in the in the full dose
and the half dose
it seems it seems to be that for a lot
of people it's just kind of confusing
and unsettling
whereas the trust the full doses it kind
of takes a little bit of the control
from you and you you tend to surrender
to it a little bit more and there's a
certain clarity
um to it so uh so yeah so go on
yeah so um i i had
no control right it started and it was
it was interesting it started and i saw
these trolls and i was laying on a
mattress and they were
there were these trolls in the in the
corner watching me
oh and i've never gotten trolls
patrols i've never gotten the trolls
yourself you've never got
i've
they're not the purple lady they're like
little gremlin-like things
um and i've had them actually both
experiences that i saw the purple lady i
also saw trolls
but it was weird i could see trolls in
the corner so i could
this is when i could still see so i
could see the ceiling i could see these
trolls watching me
i got up to use the bathroom came back
the trolls were still there so they were
stuck in one area watching me and then
when i fell
into it uh when i fell into it
i probably cried for most of the
experience you know and
it was from what i've read about really
high-dose mushroom experiences it was
totally typical
like i i went through every relationship
in my life and saw how i was
contributing negatively to it
uh i ended it with an overwhelming sense
of
if you're gonna put anything into the
universe it should be love because
anything you put that's negative just
adds to
the negativity in the universe i went
what i would say was outer space but it
kind of looked like
uh the beatles yellow submarine
it was so the beatles yellow submarine
where it was kind of a cart
kind of cartoon-like i couldn't see
anything right like i was way out in
outer space
uh and there were all these different
beings there
and it's hard to remember
i'd have to go back and see what i wrote
maybe i'll put that put it in the show
notes because it was more in depth
but there were there were all these
different beings and it filled me with a
sense i lost myself
completely right so i wouldn't say i had
i don't know if that qualified as an ego
death but i didn't exist anymore
and i went to this place where nothing
mattered like
nothing mattered and i thought and it
was a relief that nothing mattered
anymore
and then i kind of built it back up and
thought because i have a daughter
and i thought wait a minute some things
matter to me
they might not matter in the greater
scheme of things but my daughter
certainly matters to me and that's okay
and maybe it's better that some things
matter even if
they don't according to this this place
i was in
uh and then at that point my dad was
really ill uh and he was having a
he he's he had a physical dependency on
benzodiazepines
that just that almost killed him right
like those those drugs are just
people don't know how dangerous they are
but uh he had a paradoxical reaction and
it was killing him at that time
and it was very confusing for our family
because we were like what's going on
we didn't know what was going on for a
while and so i saw him in this trip and
he was encompassed in this black
[ __ ] demon and i looked at the demon
and i thought oh my god that tar demon
used to have
me and i used to be really ill i had i
was on a lot of medication
i was extremely depressed i had
arthritis and i got healthy i got off of
all those meds but i looked at the tar
demon and i had this overwhelming
sense of i know you
and so it's not my dad who's like who's
the bad guy kind of in the situation
he's
he's being had by this time tar demon so
i went in to grab the tar demon to pull
him away
and he grabbed my arm and started
sucking me in
and i was like okay i can't pull him out
and then this purple so i was
filled with rage at this tar demon and
then this purple lady came
and this is over the expanse of what
felt like a thousand years
because it was like four hours of not
being able to see
uh and this purple lady came and for me
she was
it was kind of 2d and very digital
and she floated over me and it looked a
lot like that hokkienism
photo it was kind of flat she was just
ahead
and she floated over me and i was filled
with a sense of
it's okay you're doing everything right
everything's going to be okay
it was overwhelming sense of that and
she just she didn't say anything right
she was just looking at me and i could
just feel that
through her eyes and she just hung out
there
and then this trip slowly ended and
that was the first time i saw her but i
ended up seeing her again
on aco dmt um but that was the first
time i saw her and i was like i have
seen
god after that it was like no like
nothing
nothing matters fill the universe with
love
don't contribute negativity um
it completely got rid of my fear of
death because it kind of felt like an
after
life experience and then
i saw this purple god lady
and it had a really lasting impression
in me
and then about a month later
uh i did aco dmt and hamilton morris
actually
suggested i try that and i was very
careless with the dosage
because you need the tiniest amount it's
this powder
and it's so strong that i didn't
understand how strong it was
so i didn't have a scale that was quite
accurate enough so i kind of eyeballed
it on the scale and i ended up doing
probably a third more than i should have
and i was in a shopping center because i
thought i was micro dosing
i was in a shopping center and the
trolls showed up
yeah luckily i was with andre at the
time oh also after that experience i got
back together with my husband
i saw him like the a really clear vision
of him and he was this like strong
gold statue character and i was like
oh who doesn't want to be with a strong
gold statue
exactly you can't you can't give that up
yeah
so so second time i saw these trolls in
the shopping center and was like i have
to go home
right now uh and i i got home
and i laid in bed and it was
probably not a high it was a i don't
like that met
like drug as much as uh shrooms
it's a it was a little bit more digital
but the same thing happened i was in bed
laying down and i was in a pretty bad
place because i was
really worried about my dad and the
purple lady showed up again and
she didn't she wasn't particularly
helpful she just
kind of floated over me and and did the
same like
you're not doing anything wrong
everything's gonna be okay kind of thing
um and then i've done i've had
psychedelic experiences sin
since then i talk a lot about it on the
podcast i don't
actually do it that often but the
they're profound experiences in there
yeah they're
a lot to think about a lot and and then
it's so it's been absolutely absurd
finding other people online
with similar experiences and people were
like well how do you know it's the same
woman and obviously i don't
but the feeling that comes along with
seeing her seems to be similar
it's not just this purple lady it's
also the feeling she gives you so
what was your experience yeah so one
um my my perspective is that
for on you know for for any listeners
hearing
someone talking about seeing trolls and
whatnot like i
certainly don't blame them for uh you
know thinking
that someone's hallucinating and and
that might very well be the case but i
do
think that that's wrong to um
uh to just dismiss the it doesn't it
still doesn't answer anything it doesn't
answer
why are people having a similar
hallucination and why
why are the hallucinations showing up in
that
particular way it's like i'm i'm uh
i'm bipolar and i've had some some
extreme
manic episodes where where i have you
know
come up with ideas that were not
grounded in reality and it's
still worth trying to understand where
those ideas come
from and and uh so so even
even worse k worst judgment of it is
like
this is just a bunch of crazy talk these
people did drugs or whatever
that's still not a satisfying answer
it's
still it's still just worth
investigating i was i would say
just like we should be looking into what
makes someone schizophrenic or
anything else i think it's pretty
important um
and then so so
also people uh on the other end of it
people um you know are are like well you
you saw this and that god how can
his um is like she's like this
isis character or something to me and
other people are like
um uh are always telling me like
different
different gods through different
religious histories that
they think that i'm describing none of
them none of them look
anything like her the way that hawking
um true them
but um you know and that's
and that's what those experiences
absolutely feel like
when you're having the experience like
with without a doubt this isn't
you don't have to take anyone's word for
it
you can have this experience by yourself
and have
this isn't just like hey i read in this
book that was written two thousand years
ago that this and that happened and
and okay we're going to just take that
as
the truth you can i i would never ask
someone to
necessarily believe anything that i'm
saying they can this is
yeah this is a lovely experiment that
anyone can do for themselves
and i don't really consider myself an
expert i don't i don't necessarily trust
my takes on it
um i find it to be endlessly
complex and and confusing the
way that i think about most of the
psychedelic experience
that i think has the most explanatory
power
for me um though
also has the most difficulty explaining
things like the purple lady
and especially i would say why people
are seeing similar things in an
ayahuasca ceremony
is that i tend to think that these
are that i tend to look at the brain
as uh kind of like the movie inside out
uh in a way where we literally have
these
so in the movie inside out where this
little girl has these
um little characters that embody the
different emotional states in her head
of like
anger and joy and sadness um
and they they look very different um
uh than than this outside world
does i think in an overly simplified
metaphor for what i kind of think is
going on
uh although there's a lot of problems
with that metaphor that i'll get into as
well
um and and kind of clarify is is that uh
that um i i think that
potentially our
our subconscious mind has entire worlds
and multiverses inside of it that our
idea that the the various hats that we
wear
in life um the the various you know your
daughter a mother a friend you know all
these
all these different things are kind of
stored and represented in different ways
in your mind that
um that have to kind of come online
really quickly each person in our life
has to be represented
um you know we might talk today and and
either one of us could have a dream
tonight and
see the other person and be doing our
brain could be creating a perfect
representation
you could tonight be doing my exact
voice saying things that are very
similar to uh what i'm saying and and
we've
will have interacted for about an hour
or so and
and the brain does this really easily
and that means that i'm stored
in your mind like there's a living like
shame
in your head now and uh
and i think that however the mind is
is doing that it's also
um our our conscious awareness is not
being
um fed much of what is
happening in these worlds yeah and
that uh that the psychedelic experience
is a window into those uh into those
worlds
and because because we might need some
of the same
kind of evolved structures for say what
is the perfect woman you know maybe
there's
like oh waist to hip ratio that leads to
uh x increase in fertility or whatever
and and we have these kind of exemplars
um in our in our mind or these
archetypes i i'm
sorry that i'm not super familiar with
you or your dad but i understand that
he's into uh
archetypes it's very yes and uh i so
so when i share my ideas people often
compare them to jungian ideas which i've
actually never pursued or looked into
because i i kind of
like just pursuing my own ideas and not
having them influenced
by others so you'll have to forgive me
if if like
if if your whole upbringing was like i
get it
the archetypes and now you're having to
hear me uh
but um but i i think that
potentially that that would explain
why people are having seeing similar
things if there are kind of similar
structures in the mind that we're
artificially um stimulating
in in similar ways during uh uh
during a a psychedelic experience
so that's the basics of like
where i'm at with things and i think
there's a lot of flaws with it and
everything else and
now i could get into like my
introduction into dmt and how i met the
purple woman
and uh and stuff if you like and please
interrupt me and ask questions and ask
for clarity and stuff because this is
uh one i'm probably gonna talk too much
too it's crazy and three i often
uh presume people know that what i'm
talking about when they have no idea
and uh so so
when i first did um
when i first did dmt it was it was a
weird time i had just
quit drinking um the first upgrade
that's okay okay two things before you
get started
so no please interrupt anytime because
otherwise i will
just keep going um one the
the type of like major depression i had
was technically bipolar type two
so that's what i was diagnosed with when
i was like
um although i've managed to resolve
symptoms with
with diet but that and then
when i did do the uh really high dose
mushroom trip last year
it was after stopping drinking i don't
know if that has anything to do
with anything but continue
yeah i mean my two
biggest demanic episodes were right
after quitting drinking
and uh and where it were some of the
more intense experiences
um that i've had and it it seems like
chronic
if your bipolar you know alcohol can
kind of keep you in that lower
depressed state and yeah once you once
you stop
all of a sudden you can just lift off
into that manic
state really easily and and maybe
quitting cold turkey like i've done
every time is
maybe not the best way to ease into it
if you're bipolar i don't
don't know enough about this stuff but
um my
i i had uh someone
uh i was doing a show in dallas a comic
uh heard me talking i think i always
have like a few minutes of psychedelic
material
in my act or i always have um much more
than a few minutes will usually use
or lose rather uh your average audience
so i usually kept it under five
minutes or so i i was before i started
doing indie shows and
producing my own shows i was like a
regular
comedy club like hey saturday night date
night let's go and see
comedy whatever that is and so
so someone's on a date and you start
talking about a purple woman or
something like that
you're going to lose some people but um
i i someone's like have you
you see you seem like a trippy guy have
you ever done dmt
and i was like no never heard of it and
he's like well you should check out this
documentary dmt the spirit molecule
at the time i had just quit drinking and
i'm like god i've done
so many drugs in my life do i really
need to add
another drug like i feel like and i
watched um
the dmt the spirit molecule this
documentary that joe rogan was a part of
and i found it to be pretty unconvincing
scientifically and i i was i found it
pretty questionable uh in a lot of ways
so i also don't blame people when they
when they question my perspective in
fact yeah i encourage them
to um but um
i there was just something
about the reports in the documentary
that were like
i was like well i'm not going to go my
whole life without
taking off basically yeah like no way
and so sign me up so i went to this
guy's house and
he's a computer programmer there's a
lady's a neuroscientist
i was like all right you know they seem
like intelligent enough people that have
their stuff together
smokes dmt for the first time and uh
again people people can watch me tell
the story on comedy central but
the the gist of it is i just immediately
go into this
uh this different world
after three hits anyway i go into this
different world
full of um uh
like microchip looking digital
cities and these
uh this like these like almost buildings
or structures talking to me in these
ways
and of like welcome
so happy to see you that's something
that's always struck me
as as strange because that happens
so for a listener i've since smoked dmt
or had a breakthrough experience rather
about a hundred times or so um that's a
lot
way more how long do the how long do the
experiences last
five to ten minutes oh okay so it's not
like six hours of
shrooms no yeah yeah
some sometimes up to like 15 minutes and
it depends there's things you can do to
elongate does it feel longer
yeah when you set a thousand lifetimes
that's like
i mean sometimes it it does literally
feel like five minutes
other times i i have i have definitely
lived more experientially i've
i've lived more lifetimes in a dmt space
than this like
the the this 40 years of life that i've
had on this planet
that's an interesting way to put it
sliver compared to
the amount of time so it's hard to say
like you know if
if you're if you're like
you have to pick one that's real which
one is it it's like well i've
spent more time in that world
that's really interesting maybe that's
why people talk about it so much too
because of the
time dilation like it felt like decades
when i did mine
yeah so yeah and i think that there's
certainly plenty of neural scientific
explanations for
time dilation which is that say you are
going into your subconscious well your
subconscious has to be
yeah for for us to be thinking of things
to
blab out of our mouths as we're as we're
talking right now or planar day or
anything else
the the amount of calculations and
and different synaptic firing and
everything going on in the mind
must be happening at such an incredibly
rapid rate so much faster than our than
our conscious experience
that if if it is truly if it happens to
be
if not on dmt other substances
kind of creating um a a connection to
the subconscious
it you might be relating to time on that
level of processing
and that might explain some of the some
of the dilation
and yeah certainly
i i i'm not saying that no no one's
seeing a purple lady in a different
universe or whatever will get into that
um might very well be but
but absolutely there are psychedelics
that are tapping into the subconscious
like
without a doubt you know there's past
traumas emerging in people
it's often times like it's a lot lots of
times
shower thoughts on steroids you know so
yeah so you'll have like a thousand of
them and and in
my guesses is that much like a shower
thought is just
you know the um uh
the the different ideas that are on your
subconscious mind
and uh just floating below your
conscious awareness
one of them popping to the surface and
you're like whoa i had this profound
insight
well there might have been a hundred
other profound insights just below the
surface that you're just not being fed
or gaining access to and psychedelic
experience
is letting you see more of the sausage
being made and getting a little more of
like the sneak previews
into into some of those ideas and
um and so
so that was always my thinking um
early on is that this is and
and mind you before i did dmt i probably
had like two or three hundred
mushroom experiences and so so that was
the only way that i ever thought about
mushrooms
i it never even occurred to me to think
about it as like some
parallel universe or something like that
until i did dmt
and then that's kind of my view after
that
like the super high dose one i was like
i'm pretty convinced that
this is just a connection that you've
there's formed i'm one of those people i
think
there's some sort of connection you get
to
to like a different thing than this than
this yeah like a weird telephone line
or something yeah i'm in that category
of people it's like i don't know
subconscious yes but like i think there
are things out there
that we're seeing on psychedelics well
if i were to
if i were to smoke dmt in front of you
like
right now i would i would without a
doubt
um be like yep forget all the
subconscious stuff that i was just
talking about i
i it's i just saw there's something
wrong
with it and no doubt about it
and uh i
for whatever reason and whatever biases
that i have
i i tend to in the integration process
walk a lot of that back and i i don't
know if i'm just stubbornly
um like hyper rationalist or something
in in that way
i don't know if it's uh my religious
upbringing that made me
kind of like a uh angry uh atheist early
on in my life and
and that i have a bit of ptsd from that
that i'm
kind of naturally averse to that
perspective but i also there there's a
lot of things that it doesn't explain
like you wear headphones and play music
during a dmt experience
why is the music altering that
experience so if you're if you're truly
creating a connection
why is your music here influencing
their entire entire world i'm not saying
that it's not it's just an interesting
question i i'd like that's a very good
point though
and uh and then
the other um
the other aspect is it's
weird that they're always ready for you
like there's always like a whole red
carpet
rolled out and waiting for like
hey shane welcome back or whatever i
have not had that
really i haven't done dmt though i've
just done the high-dose mushrooms but
when i
like went out to that other universe i
got
completely ignored right like the purple
lady showed up
but i was just there watching what was
going on
you know kind of floating around and
they like these beings were just going
about their
their business it looked like i'd been
transported out there or was seeing
things but they didn't care that i was
there
that's interesting i've never had
they're always very excited to see me
um and and that was always suspicious to
me that's interesting to hear that
because i
it was weird that i never like caught
him off guard or anything you know i was
just out for a hike recently
and i went to take a leak and and
you know it's cold out and i'm in
wisconsin and like no one's on these
trails and sure enough
the one time i go to take a leak some
guy comes around the
corner and this poor sucker trying to
take in
nature now has to see my flaccid
shriveled dick out and and
but i've never had an experience like
that with
i i've never caught these aliens with
their pants down
you know i've never they're they're
always
it's so like why why is their world
just like set up and ready to go
and waiting for me suspicious every time
that i
arrive like is this how they're busying
themselves
is just waiting till the next time
some weird comic smokes dmt
to come and say hi to them to give him a
bunch of messages that he's definitely
going to forget
and even if he didn't no one would
believe anyway
so it's it's
it's strange um i had
i had another experience uh
and this was i so i i used to take
antidepressants for this depression
like a high dose of ssri and there was
this was when i was young and completely
unaware of anything
and i um i took
cough syrup not you know because i had a
cough it wasn't
to take for fun but i took coughs yeah i
wasn't tripping out on cough syrup on
purpose
but it had dextromethorphin in it yeah
and i went to bed
i took my antidepressants took cough
syrup went to bed and i woke up about an
hour later
and i think what had happened is i'd
given myself serotonin syndrome
but i woke up i had a fever i threw up
and then i hallucinated
and it was the same kind of thing i was
speaking to these aliens
and there were these baby baby aliens
and a mom
alien and the baby aliens were like why
can she see us why is she here
and the mom alien was like oh just leave
her alone
and it was and i was talking to these
baby aliens and this mom alien but i
wasn't supposed to be there so the
couple of experiences i've
had like i haven't had welcoming
experiences they've just been i've just
popped in there and they're like
what's happening this isn't supposed to
be interesting
and here i had written off ssris
as being something that had been
demanded
by uh by a population of
people poorly understanding their
emotions and
having a hard time being uncomfortable
things and writing depression off as
a mental illness rather than rather than
something that is maybe clueing you into
things going
wrong in your life but it turns out if
you just mix them with
cough syrup you can see aliens
i do not recommend that is a very
uh yeah we're not recommending that but
but that's a
thank you for sharing that anyway um
so yeah so early on
my my first couple experiences i was
less convinced than the people giving me
dmt that
what i was seeing was some like
alternate reality not that it didn't
look like one
but to me it was like you described a
flat it looked like i was watching a
movie
of of something and
they were like you haven't done enough
yet and i said
yes i am like it doesn't get any crazier
than
what i just saw and they're like no i
don't think you've done enough
and so i went about seeing how to get
more dmt in my
into my brain which i another thing i
don't necessarily recommend and
um i
started considering the idea
of like well okay let's just
let's just take these things for face
value you know
while i'm in the experience and
why resist you know resisting these
psychedelic experiences doesn't do you
any good
it's it
a good heuristic is to try to try to
surrender
and be accepting not every little idea
but
but just as a general rule of thumb and
so i was like maybe i'm resisting
and so i was like you know i'll just
interact with these things and so this
thing that was
uh it i was like what are you
yeah and they'd be like oh i'm
everything
and i was like and so like i i do that
you know i have this whole like okay
this crazy experience
get done and i'd be like were they
though
i have follow-up questions and then i'd
smoke dmt again
and i'd be like what so what are you
again and they'd be like i'm everything
i'm like
i don't think you are i think that i
think that you're
in my head and that this is classic
egocentrism that everything
when i use egocentrism i don't mean um
like egotistical patting ourselves on
the back i i mean
i mean that by by the constraint that we
only have access to the information
we have access to we are all born and
come into this world the center of our
own
universe of perception and just as much
as there are
all sorts of interesting things
happening in a town over or in some city
in
in uh bangladesh or something like that
uh
that that there might be lots of
interesting things happen that would be
providing me valuable information right
now i simply don't have access
to information that i don't have access
to
and so my brain has to make the best use
of
the information that i do have access to
which
and so it tends to overvalue say
the things that i'm looking at in in the
room that i'm in or the conversation
that i'm in
involved in and it tends to kind of
overestimate that information and
and there there's no
[Music]
there's no choice but to like the
default being the center of everything
and so i'm like having these
these long like philosophical
conversations with these things
about this and they're like consider and
they're like yeah i don't know
i'm everything and and i'm like
yeah but if say you were inside my head
everything to you everything that's
inside of my head that
you have access to would feel like
everything
that there is but i'm telling you
there's also an external reality
that you aren't seeing that you don't
have conscious awareness of and they're
like
whatever dude i'm everything don't
believe me yeah
they were like they were indifferent
they weren't like looking to convince me
necessarily
or any but they were you know seemingly
they just found
my inquiries amusing and
and then after a while i was like
okay say you're everything like what do
we
what do i do with that and then they're
like well just
tell people and i was like that was
when when they said that that was the
funniest thing i could ever imag
because because i'd had all of these
like strange they
i i'd be like you're everything prove it
and then they'd
be like like show me like
a zillion lifetimes of everything that's
happened
in in 15 million universes so that i'd
be like
whoa well that does look like everything
that's a convincing
argument for you being everything but
then when i would press it further
it would always do these it would always
give me these
crazy like visual things and i'd be like
see there you go again that's the
that's this magic trick you're using to
distract me you're still like not
answering my questions
and so this is like going back and forth
through like ages it seems
and and and so the idea
of like oh good just tell people i'm
like tell people
what like oh you know there's like
fractals going
like oh like what what do you mean
tell people there's nothing to tell that
it's
like i don't know what's going on it
looks like utter madness to me i have no
way of articulating
at this i'm certainly not going to go
out and and
and just like get on a soapbox and just
start announcing this to the world
and they're like oh no don't do that
like be careful
you know be careful how you tell people
and and then i was so then after a while
i was like
all right well and so at this time i'm
coming up with
a lot of ideas about why
and they're exceptionally
and probably unnecessarily complex um
for example like when you mentioned that
everything
this is just going to happen she said
this is all just going to happen again
and again
um or something like that and and
it's okay and don't worry about it
well i had that feeling early on and i
eventually got that from the purple
woman as well but i i had that
that feeling early on and it was uh
another bias that i have is i don't most
people have like uh
um most people when they have a
spiritual experience
they're like yes see
someone's looking out for me when i have
the same experience i'm like
oh god oh no this is well something's
something's looking out for me and it's
done a [ __ ] job so far
and and i so when i
when a lot of people like have these
synchronicities and are like
wow there's god winking at me just let
me know
god's around i have a synchronicity and
i'm like am i in the truman show what
the [ __ ] is happening
like i i just don't
uh that
it's not a comforting feeling for me and
i say that
because um
as a disclaimer that that it's very
possible
that i've thought way more about these
things than needs be
and it's so much so that that
i'm i'm making even less sense than just
taking things at face value
but i'll give you an example of of kind
of the
scientific-ish sounding insights i was
having
um with no evidence but found it in
scientific reasoning
um so i would i would smoke dmt
i would have these i and i would see
what would look like a loop
like immediately i'd be pulled back from
whatever scene that i was in
and i would see it expand in into my
past and future and then beyond my past
and then
well into my future and it would look
like this infinite loop and all of this
happens again and again and there's and
there's um
[Music]
you know this is uh predetermined or
something like that or there's no
there's no escaping it which i always
thought was kind of horrifying in that i
you got to relive i had that yeah
so you have to like relive your mistakes
all
every single time over and over again
well my
mine was like i didn't
when i told you i got filled with i was
kind of told or shown that
nothing mattered it it was it was
it also zoomed in on earth and i was
like well there are so many people
suffering
yeah and it was like none of that
matters right
um so it wasn't it was it was basically
you it was weird like the purple lady
came said you're doing as much as you
can like everything's gonna be
okay but it was also coupled with
because none of the suffering matters in
the first place
so it wasn't like we're looking out for
you it was just like
nothing really matters but good job
kind of it certainly does feel like a
lot a lot of this
is just uh in in in that state what i'd
often felt like was this was just
the kind of inevitable properties of
whatever the big bang or whatever you
know every this was just
when you create the big bang that
happened in that gave rise
uh to our universe this is everything
that came after it was just
the inevitable conclusion of everything
that happened from that very moment
that that happened and it was never
going to go any other way
i hate that idea but it's what it feels
like um
so so i i was hyper focused on
on that aspect of it which always
happened right at the beginning
i was hung up on it and so what i but
what i started noticing and thinking
about
over time was if this is instead the
subconscious and this is a part of how
our ideas and memories are formed
i don't know if you've ever had like a
near-death experience there's something
similar where
where or or you you almost
drive your car off a cliff or hit
someone or something like that your
brain
zooms back in time to like thinking of
all the different
possibilities of how that could have
gone or
making sure you you don't do that again
or drive slower in the rain next time or
whatever
and you so you project into the future
ways that
things could have gone you you zoom
backwards into
into the past and like reflect on what
just happened and
and if you have uh if you have an event
where
um where uh you're in a like
i broke my feet a couple of years ago
and i remember the moment that i did
that
it was like all of my life just
was shown to me in like a moment and i
don't think it's a fun
little nostalgic trick trip down memory
lane i think it's the brain
frantically searching past uh through
past experiences being like have we seen
a macgyver episode that can get us out
of this
situation like what do we have to draw
from
and and and so and then there's like
different
uh uh you have to consider different
like parallel universes had i made this
choice things would have went
differently and
and so these simulations are kind of
happening all of the time and
in the subconscious mind and i
i think that perhaps that when you
smoke dmt and your brain is all of the
sudden
thrust into this uh really novel
uh experience that it's quickly trying
to make sense of
it's trying to predict the future and
searching back into the past and it's
going so far that it's it's going
it's projecting simulations of what life
might have been like before you were
alive through our evolutionary history
and so on
and the processing power just runs out
at some point there's just
only so far you can like think into the
future or the past and at that point
uh the the kind of simulation becomes
foggy
and that fogginess creates a bit of like
a almost like a mirage like a horizon
that looks like it's bending and as
they're bending those two the past and
the future look
as if they're coming together and then
your brain just
fills in um the rest like um
um uh like uh
uh object permanence or if you're like
the
you're the reason why peek-a-boo works
is because because
kids until a certain age don't realize
that something still
exists when they when they can't see it
it's something that you have to learn
over time
and so your brain's kind of using this
object permanence again this is all just
kind of a metaphor
and filling in a gap and it's making
that feel like a loop
right and so that's like okay that's an
interesting
insight and now maybe i don't need to be
maybe we aren't all
stuck in the same universe going around
and around again
and maybe this is a way of tapping into
the the way in which our brain
projects our futures and so that's just
kind of the idea
just to give you a sense of the like
overly complicated way in which i
i grasp at straws to explain these in in
a semblance of a scientific way and so
i'm doing all of this and then around
the 20th time so within the 15th time
i'm i'm coming up with a lot of other
kind of pseudo-scientific explanations
and stuff
and uh and i
i kept on asking um
i kept on asking it to
show me something i was like if you
really
if you want me to tell people about this
i need to
actually know that this is real
and i'm not just imagining this you need
to
show me something that is outside of my
mind that i wouldn't have access to i
don't know how you're going to do that
but that's what you're going to have to
do to convince me
so around the 20th time i smoke dmt i
have this big experience all this
stuff happens doesn't really matter at
the end of it i see this purple woman
um people can see this uh me tell this
story on
on this comedy central clip as well but
i'll link that below
yeah um and and i see this purple woman
and the moment i saw her the first time
that i
saw her on dmt it was like we had known
each other for
thousands of lifetimes uh it was i had
never when people talk about like
soul mates or something like that and
you see someone and you just know it was
it was like we had been friends or
something
i've never gotten i've never figured out
what our vibe because people are always
like
like comedy central was like shane moss
has some purple dmt girlfriend i'm like
not sure she's my girlfriend i don't
know i don't know
what she is but the vibe that i get is a
little
and sometimes it's like a mothery but a
lot of times it's like um
it's like a i guess
kind of sexy but like playful like
platonic
friendship um sort of
thing as the vibe that i seem to get and
i've heard a lot of other
um people kind of report the the same
thing since
at the time i'd never heard about this
purple woman by the way in
in case people are like you just heard
about the purple woman and then you
and it yeah your psychedelic experience
and
and blah blah i mean those are all great
things worth considering and
i considered them and it's just in my
opinion not the case at all
but um i um
so so i see this purple woman there's
this carnival there's some guy playing a
like piano back there's like some ferris
wheel or something
and this purple woman that uh we're both
like
oh my god like how long has it been well
this is crazy and we're very excited to
see one another
and then and then she says it was
usually at like
when the mt was wearing off and like we
both
realized and and i had this feeling
multiple times
where we both realized that we are now
needing
needing to say goodbye and then like a
bit of sadness coming along with that
and not knowing when we're going to see
each other again and then
her saying like oh all of this just
keeps on happening again and again
don't worry about it we'll see each
other again and
um and yeah so that's the first time i i
see her and and i i told some
some of my friends that were there that
weren't they weren't comedians or
anything just some people in dallas
and i i honestly i just
didn't think anything significant about
it seeing
seeing that the first time i saw that
purple woman that was like
not it wasn't even that interesting i
was just like well dmt is crazy what are
you gonna do
see all sorts of crazy things like i
didn't really even think about it and
then
the next day i went to austin and
for a while i was on a kick with trying
to give dmt to
as many of my close friends as possible
to be like what what are you seeing in
there like what
you know to get a report back and i and
so i wouldn't tell them
like what my experience was other than
like this is
just the most intense interesting
experience that i've
that i've ever had and uh
and so my friend um
my friend bob i uh
um bob kozravi in austin
uh i go to his house i give him dmt
i'm telling them like the first two
minutes are really intense
um don't be surprised if it's like way
too overwhelming
after that things calm down and the
real meat of it is like the following
few minutes and then
um and then the you know you'll have a
uh you'll you'll be done in
in 10 minutes or whatever and i
i think i told them like if the music's
too intense take off your headphones or
or whatever um but that was about it
and then i just told them to smoke as
much as possible um
at the time that was like the
rudimentary
way of like how much dmt do you do i
don't know
as much as you can smoke the only the
only constraint
with dmt is not smoking uh enough of it
as far as it
like once you've broken through you're
not able to hold anything or do anything
like
you're gone and that's that you're not
going to be and until that point
you haven't done enough um and and so
he's smoking dmt and i'm just like
encouraging him to
and he's like coughing and stuff he's
not used to
smoking anything and and so i have no
idea how much he's actually getting in
or how much is being coughed
so i'm like well he's he's still
together so
just like keep going and now he's like
hits in or whatever and
finally he's like hands me the ball back
closes his eyes
and he immediately starts freaking out
and he's like
oh i've had too much i've had too much
i've had too much i've had too much and
i'm just like sitting there
you know watching my timer like okay and
and for like a minute straight like i've
had too much
i've had too much oh god oh god and it's
like clearly he's distressed and like a
minute into this
i'm like yeah i think he might have had
too much
i might have just wrecked my friend's
brain
and uh and then like another 30 seconds
into it he finally like
takes the headphones off and he's like
shane
i i had too much and i was like bob it's
only been a minute and a half i told you
that i told you the first two minutes
can be overwhelming just hang in there
and the second he
heard that and heard my voice he just
like the sense of
peace just washed over him he sat back
he starts smiling and he's like
oh god they love you and i was like yeah
there's this like
sense of going home and stuff which if
we had time i
i'd get really into why why that's a
common thing
um but uh but anyway um
he's like and i was like yeah this
there's a there's a real feeling of love
he's like no no shane they love you
and i was like what are you talking
about and he's like there's this purple
woman in here
that says that she knows you
and she just needs you to know that she
cares about you
and i was like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about and then like
afterwards he came out of it and he's
like
well i went in and there's all these
like i forget exactly what he said like
i think one of these like self-dribbling
basketball things or something like that
that terence mckenna used to talk about
that i've never
been fortunate enough to see myself but
like you with trolls or whatever some
something
like that when he when he first arrived
it was just like this
land of these weird little beings and
when he freaked out
they scurried as well in my kid and they
were like
peeking behind from things like at him
and it was freaking him out and then
they were getting freaked out
and and
then when he took the headphones off
and heard my voice um
that he said that um that the things in
there like heard my voice too
and came out and they were like is that
shane and he's like
you guys know shane and they're like
yeah he comes in here all the time
and then they and then this purple woman
comes out and then it
there's like this carnival and and he's
like
yeah there's like this guy playing this
keyboard and all this
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
and
uh and and that's that's what happened
this purple woman
apparently uh
knew me and needed bob to tell her that
he knew me and
that was like right that was shortly
after i was kind of like
pressing these spaces for uh
evidence of that you know this wasn't
just in my head and was something
outside of me
and that was weird and i didn't know
what to think of it
and i still don't and then
you know i just kept on exploring and
then
since that time i have come up with
tons of different ideas and explanations
much of them i've already kind of
discussed but have just been expanded on
um and and
if if if people hear um i i have a
i had a podcast with a dmt and a
neuroscientist
a dmt researcher and neuroscientist
andrew gallimore
on my podcast not too long ago that we
had a
very long conversation about some of my
thoughts on this stuff
but just experientially i started seeing
this purple woman not every time
but once in a while and it was the same
sort of thing every time
it was real happy to see one another
sad when we were leaving and she'd do
this thing where she would uh
she would exp she would to cheer me up
like as we were saying goodbye she would
spin around and then explode into
fractals
and then um kind of like a
a scene in a movie cgi where a vampire
like
explodes into bats looked like that and
then
those fractals would become like me and
i was them and i was everything and then
they'd be sucked out and then they'd
become her again and then she'd be like
yeah see ya
it's just this weird fun little trick
that she
has and then um and then
lots of so within that
i'm like quite stubbornly looking for
scientific explanations um for this and
i was trying to brush up on
some physics stuff because i hadn't read
a physics book in
ages and recalled
something or other about how there's you
know
12 different dimensions we don't have we
can't perceive most of them
and and possibly it's because some of
them are like shaped differently and
rolled up in different ways and just
under our perception
i didn't quite remember what so i was
trying to google image
that uh that concept i don't know what i
was putting in but something about like
different dimensions that you can't see
in physics or something like that or
parallel universes
whatever i was doing i'm like you know
google imaging and it's like pictures of
space and planes and
physics things and is a universe shaped
like a
like a saddle or is it flood or you know
i'm looking at all these things
and all out of nowhere
here's this purple woman just
in like this google image search and i'm
like
what the [ __ ] that's her
and and i send it to bob and i'm like is
this what you saw and he's like yep
that's her all right
and then i look into it and it's this
guy hawkinhism
uh who who does who lives in turkey
um has done a bunch of dmt and and
has an incredible aptitude for
uh yeah that's for sure digitally
painting what
what he sees and and pulls even his
stuff
that i can't honestly say like
i have seen this exactly like if people
look up his stuff
maybe like the these universal
transmissions that he makes
which are like a good example of like i
can't
i can't say that i've seen that exact
thing
but when i look at it the
connection that it has with me
takes my breath away and it's there's
just
something in the patterns um or
whatever that he's that he's pulling out
that resonates
uh on some level like
i i mean it's it's intense
and and so you know so then i
then i'm like what is this [ __ ]
purple woman and then
weird stuff has happened since that time
i want to wrap up but i have
i have one way one way to finish it and
um i'll tell you my experience first and
then i'll ask you about yours
sure but my experience with so i
probably had
20 pretty intense
like you know four or five hour
hallucination trips from
shrooms or aco dmt and in my experience
i can tell if i'm doing it too much
because i don't really benefit from it
in my real
real life right so if i come back and i
haven't learned
a ton um i'm like you know what maybe
maybe i need to take take some time take
take a break because i've found you know
if i have a really good experience i'll
be like okay
i want to go back that was insanely
interesting right that was the most
interesting thing i've ever experienced
let me
go delve into different parts of it and
if it starts and it's still insanely
interesting each time but if i start
coming back
to reality and it hasn't benefited me
then i give it a pretty lengthy break
like i'll take
a couple of years yeah what's your
what's your
uh i guess recommendation for people
on frequency well my first
recommendation would be to
never follow my advice on like all
everyone that knows me and all of my
good friends
know to do about half whatever i
i tell them uh to do and
i am a bit reckless and i'm a little
more toward the
exploratory side of things so there's
lots of
like i've partnered with uh in on past
tours the organization the
multidisciplinary association of
psychedelic studies
which is you know like scientific rigor
we're going to use mdma for ptsd and
you're going to sit and talk with a
therapist and that's
one thing and then i made a documentary
psychonautics and the
term psychonaut as like
weirdly uh all all of these words are
they hallucinogenics are they say you
know there's a lot of
uh of discussion about how we're
supposed to
talk about these things and a psychonaut
definitely leans toward
like uh creating this ridiculous like
heroic narrative of like wow i'm an
interesting explorer or whatever but
what i'm most i am mostly after the
exploration and the
experience so it depends on what you're
after because i definitely
like when someone's like should i do dmt
i'm like i don't
i have no idea i i used to
i used to tell people like my good
friends i'd be like
you're missing out if you don't have
this experience i'd still kind of lend
that
or tend to lean that way but
i in terms of therapeutic value
mushrooms have been the most therapeutic
thing for me in terms of like
understanding my depression
understanding myself being a more
empathetic
person a creative aid everything else
dmt is more just like hey do you like
bungee jumping
like dmt might be the psychedelic for
for you it's it's a lot more of just
like
holy crap what is that and
and for some people
mushrooms don't have any therapeutic uh
uh
don't provide any therapeutic help and
dmt actually does
for a lot of people are like i saw i'm
no longer scared of death
i had an opposite experience i was like
perfectly comfortable with death
and then i smoked dmt i'm like i am
terrified i'm not going to die
like i uh
i spoke to mdm like oh no i might be an
infinite being and there's no end to
this and
i i could jump off of a building to only
find out that i've actually
my consciousness has just been a
sidewalk the whole time
waiting for what i thought was my head
to smash into it and now i'm just a
sidewalk being here observing things
stepping on me like i don't i don't know
what i am anyway
yeah and and so
and so uh i
i i i don't
i don't personally get any relief from
those very things that might give a
different person
all of the relief that they that they
need in life
or maybe someone's lost a loved one
recently and having an experience like
that
gives them hope that they're going to be
reunited one day or something like that
and
and i'll tell you from having um i i had
a
overdose on pain pills once and
um i think that i died or close to it
and it was exactly like a dmt uh
experience when i did it in fact had i
not
had dmt experiences i think the outcome
would have been different because i was
i thought i was in the dmt space i was
like yay dmt
hooray i'm back and then i was like wait
a second
did i smoke dmt i was like when did i
smoke to you
like no then how am i seeing this dmt
space
oh i had pain pills and
mitch mixed it with scotch i think i'm
dying and then i was able to
be like get out of here and i was able
to like
jolt myself out of it that's interesting
that's interesting because that that
experience i had when i
and it was like you know uh i was young
and the
cough syrup i didn't realize interacted
with my antidepressants that i'd been
taking for 10 years
um but that was the same thing like i
was not well
i threw up i had a really high fever
like i couldn't move very well and i was
hallucinating like
it wasn't i don't know what happened
there but it wasn't a safe place to be
so the it's interesting i don't know how
dangerous that actually was but it
certainly wasn't
good yeah yeah so i mean
in terms of i i'm not i try not to be
prescriptive in life
in any way and i i think like
one one of the great things that came
out of my
me having to go to a psych ward well
my documentary was being filmed
was the documentary ended up
coming that automatic disclaimer and had
that not happen
it would have just been about some guy
that had 20
perfect years of psychedelic experiences
that helped his life a bunch and and was
like hey guys this has helped me so much
in my life it's amazing why
and it might have been too evangelical
and
interesting and so i'm happy if i was
going to be
uh if i was going to have an experience
like that i'm glad it was in that
um in that context where other people
perhaps got to
uh benefit from it um but uh
yeah i mean for my money
i love what like johns hopkins
and um maps and stuff is doing
i i started doing psychedelics as a
young
dumb um kid doing
you know not thinking about dosage or
integration or setting intentions or
creating a
safe space and like like
like like someone going to a [ __ ]
shopping center and trying a new drug
like that's a horrible idea yeah i do
not recommend that
i i don't recommend doing that and i've
done
i've done worse than that i've done so
many stupid things
like that and and it's one of the
unfortunate
um it's it's one of the unfortunate
impacts of the war on drugs
and the the stigma that all of the kind
of
ridiculous propaganda has has uh
created is that
people that are looking for help don't
have
any choice but to go to like
try to like hopefully get what is
hopefully
mdma on the streets because they're on
they've tried everything else in life
and
their ptsd is ruining their family and
everything else
and and i
so hopefully to me the path forward
is a
hope scientific legitimacy
leading to policy change
leading to normalizing these experiences
leading to safer containers
and more knowledge for people to do them
in
and not having adulterates and
and having
the drug you actually think that you're
taking in the dose that
you should be taking and um knowing
and having some ex experienced people
guiding you
through it at least to start
and then once you have that training
then we can all go to burning man and
do whatever yeah i completely agree
uh i think that's a good place to wrap
it up where can people find you online
uh go to shanemoss.com has all of my
stuff
i have three albums
you can check out that are like free on
spotify and whatnot
my main thing that i care about is my
podcast
here we are where i interview a
different scientist each week
um a lot of psychology stuff and and uh
whatnot and uh unfortunately i have very
few psychedelic episodes
so sorry but there are some on there if
you go digging there's some pretty big
ones
and um um
yeah my documentary psychonautics if you
are into the psychedelic stuff which you
don't know me from anything else if
you're listening to me for the first
time so
uh check that out and yeah i i started
uh so my the rug's been pulled out from
under
i was making 95 of my income from live
touring and i've
scrambled to uh uh
adjust and do things and within that i
started making video
of of my podcast and putting it on
youtube and
uh and have no idea how to do
any of that so right now although i have
like
a halfway decent podcast following i
have like
almost no following on youtube so i'd
love for
your audience to jump over there and
give a few episodes a shot and see what
they think
okay i'll put that in show notes and in
the youtube description as well
thank you thank you very much for coming
on that was very interesting
yeah it was interesting to hear your
stories as well thanks for having me
[Music]
you